bienvenidos a reporteros el magazine de
los grandes reportajes de france 24
hoy los llevaremos a españa en 2020 unos
50.000 niños estaban bajo el cuidado del
estado español un número alto debido a
las fallas graves en el sistema judicial
en españa' la decisión de separar a los
niños de sus padres no la toma un juez
sino los trabajadores sociales y a
menudo se vuelve irreversible la
intervención de los servicios sociales
ha afectado a los progenitores pero
también a los niños que terminan de
crecer la mayoría de las veces en
centros de menores estas estructuras
80% privadas son objeto de numerosos
escándalos en españa' gestión opaca
personal no siempre cualificado y ésta
trata sexual se cuentan entre las
denuncias de hecho la policía descubrió
el año pasado en mallorca que 16 jóvenes
menores de edad bajo la tutela del
estado formaban parte de una red de
prostitución varias familias dieron
testimonio a france24 sobre las
dificultades que encuentran para
recuperar la custodia de sus hijos
los padres denuncian que la pobreza en
el hogar es el mayor problema para
restituir el núcleo familiar a
continuación el reportaje de anna is
quedar y laura campo
[Música]
es un primer quitar a mi hijo si pues
sin justicia sin tener nada contra mí
bien
y
la administración es un monstruo que ha
tomado una decisión y no cambia
en españa había alrededor de 50.000
niños tutelados en enero de los primeros
hace 7 años maría era una joven madre
cuando comenzó su pesadilla
no te esperas en la calle en la acera
esperando que los niños salgan y yo vi
que mi hijo no sale hasta que cerraron
la puerta
digo y como que mi hijo no está digo
dónde está mi hijo todo el mundo me daba
de lado todo el mundo ninguna
explicación nadie absolutamente nadie
la comisaria y la escuela no le dan
respuesta
[Música]
al cuarto quinto día que me dijeron que
está ahí
recogido por el estado para de la gallá
en cataluña la diga ya es una
institución de ayuda social a la
infancia tiene la facultad de retirar la
tutela parental por sí misma a veces
simplemente por precaución el hijo de
maría le fue arrebatado cuando estaba en
pleno proceso de divorcio de su segundo
marido el padrastro de su hijo una
situación familiar considerada e
inestable por la administración es muy
moderno en españa si tú te divorcias ya
es un motivo para ellos y una razón que
te refiere tu hijo
ellos me acusaron que nuestro bien
mental
y que ayuda a mediano
[Música]
hace 12 años francisco pasó por el mismo
calvario junto con su primera esposa
adoptaron un bebé la pequeña esmeralda
aquí en esta piscina aprendió a nadar
conmigo
igual que tantas otras primeras cosas
tras un año de convivencia con la niña
la pareja se divorció francisco vuelve a
casarse con anabel muy bien muy bien
durante dos años esmeralda vive entre
sus dos familias adoptivas
estas están muy bien son al principio de
todo en el año 2006 te acuerdas
mira aquí con irene
cuando la de calle al se entera del
divorcio no finaliza el proceso de
adopción y se lleva a esmeralda
piensa en ella cómo se sentiría
por muy mal y rota
destrozada
como si a ti te arrancaran tus padres
con tres años como como te notarías
hundida un día
de repente se le rompe su mundo no se
despide del colegio no se despide de sus
amiguitos no se despidió de la familia
sin ver el entorno de la niña así es que
para ccoo les llegó a decir ponerme aquí
una cámara de vídeo las 24 horas del día
durante un mes y cuando lo hayáis visto
todo las 24 horas del día
decidme en qué estamos fallando que
estamos haciendo mal
esmeralda fue colocada en un lugar de
acogida francisco tiene prohibido
acercarse a ella hasta que sea mayor de
edad mientras tanto decidió ayudar a
otros padres que tenían dificultades con
la administración uno de los miembros
activos de su asociación es maría
17 años los granos
ahora
bueno tú tranquila que lo vamos a luchar
yo vamos a conseguir
seguidamente hay otras familias otras
madres y otros padres la misma situación
que la mía o muy parecida y es cuando
decidimos asociarnos unirnos para
cambiar este sistema porque pensamos que
es muy injusto familiar
hoy dan la bienvenida a un nuevo miembro
para hablar y me pusieron en una
habitación a mis niños en otra también
me pasó exactamente lo mismo me citaron
se llevaron a la niña y a mí me dijeron
que me podía ir a mi casa y se la
quedaron no es un caso no es un caso
aislado en la problema que es una
asociación muy humilde el sentido que
nosotros no tenemos más recursos que
nuestro propio interés nosotros en estos
momentos somos más de 1000 familias
para defender la potestad de sus hijos
los padres solo tienen una opción
iniciar una demanda y contratar un
abogado
así es como francisco conoció a enrique
ha llevado más de 100 casos en toda
españa'
cuando hay un riesgo sobre un menor que
no sea un técnico de la administración
sin cualificación muchas veces quien
decida la retirada esto es muy grave
debe ser el juez
en españa' 50.000 niños son colocados
bajo la tutela del estado por decisión
exclusiva de los servicios sociales esto
es cinco veces más que en francia
la de gaia es juez y parte y tiene
plenos poderes
los técnicos de infancia como menos
niños tienen menos trabajo tienen o sea
que cuando lo hacemos es porque tiene
que ser así y siempre siempre siempre
está en una resolución y te aseguro que
están muy más muy tiene muchos más
fundamentos de derecho una resolución de
tutela edad generalitat de cataluña que
una sentencia judicial
isabel es la responsable de suspender la
patria potestad para el sector de
tarragona nos llegan unas valoraciones
por parte de los diferentes equipos ya
sea de salud ya sea una escuela ya sea
de la policía de un particular
desde el servicio lo que se hace primero
es pasar un instrumento de cribaje que
tenemos ya que utiliza todo el
departamento toda la de gaia nos marca y
así es una situación de riesgo si es una
situación de desamparo
o de atención inmediata
la de gaia está satisfecha con su
eficacia sin embargo esta antigua
empleada que no estaba de acuerdo con el
sistema optó por dejar su trabajo
en la dirección general de atención a la
infancia si este edificio donde yo
estuve trabajando nueve años que es
donde se deciden las retiradas de tutela
allá detrás de cataluña se neta denuncia
a los efectos perversos de una
institución con plenos poderes
así que he visto informes con un sesgo
de subjetividad importante informes
donde se ponía no podemos asegurar que
esta mujer no tenga problemas con el
alcohol bueno pues eso lo puedes
asegurar pues no lo pongas
saca el pandero y preparar la mesa
tras cinco años sin verse maría y su
hijo vuelven a compartir su vida
cotidiana
cuando me lo quitaron
y el nicolás cuando lo recuperé
con esa edad recupere a mi hijo nicolás
y verlo así tan grande te quedas de
cuánto me he perdido de mi hijo cuánto
me he perdido
mariah sigue traumatizada por los años
de lucha contra la administración una
pelea que terminó con ese único trozo de
papel
redon de funciones de tutela de la madre
y de dónde y de tú al domicilio
es todo lo que ellos
y lo hicieron
entre los 9 y los 14 años en nicolás
creció en un centro de menores como la
mitad de los niños bajo tutela del
estado los demás son colocados en
hogares de paso
por su parte
también pidió a la administración que
volviera con su madre
con mi madre nuestra casa y dejar todo
esto
las servicios sociales me decía que mi
madre no sabía que no sabía dónde estaba
mi madre que no quería saber nada de mí
y cariño mío mira las pruebas de mi
cansancio de ti
en cinco años sumarían nunca se ha
rendido ha utilizado todos los recursos
posibles incluido el tribunal de
justicia de la unión europea
cada día es un calvario es no poder
vivir
otra vez mañana otra vez mañana otra vez
con papeles otra vez a la fuga otra vez
a la decaída otra de servicio social
otra vez psicólogo otra vez asistenta
social otra vez otra así durante cinco
años
al igual que maría sólo el 9% de los
padres consiguen sacar a sus hijos de un
centro de menores
próximo a la estación de passeig de
gràcia
acompañamos a nicolás a la última casa
donde vivió en barcelona dio una cita a
sus antiguos compañeros
se reúnen por primera vez
ahora
llegamos admirando tengo 20 años y pasé
cinco años en el centro me llamo martha
guevara martín tengo 17 años y he pasado
ocho años en el centro mismo punto
llevan a martín y el pasado ocho años en
el centro
años de sufrimiento para este hermano el
remedio fue peor que la enfermedad
mi madre no tenía dinero para
mantenernos y ella pidió una ayuda y en
vez de darnos esa ayuda pasaron a
buscarnos y nos llevaron al centro pero
en el informe ponía que mi madre era una
borracha y mi madre no ha vivido en su
vida yo vídeo trauma no podía dormir
pasada noche es fatal y tenía pesadillas
y todo
todos ellos denuncian el trato a veces
violento de los educadores y una
flagrante falta de atención álex fue la
primera víctima
de nuestro propio hogar
abusó de mí prácticamente yo esto lo
hablé con los psicólogos después de un
tiempo me dijeron que ya no se podía
hacer nada porque ya había pasado mucho
tiempo a mí me da vergüenza todo esto
pero yo lo que pretendo con esto es que
no le pasen a otros niños
en españa los casos en torno a estos
centros se están sacudiendo varias
regiones
como mínimo 7 menores tutelados que
habrían estado explotados sexualmente
rima estudia actualmente se llaman las
víctimas de explotación sexual
en enero de 2020 estalló un escándalo en
mallorca la isla más grande de baleares
donde hay unos 30 centros de menores
varios periodistas publican resultados
de una investigación condenatoria
de una práctica normalizada y extendida
incluso ellas mismas se captaban entre
ellas a veces cuando salían juntas ellas
sabían los bares donde podían conseguir
clientes y muchas veces eran al cambio
de que les pagaran las copas oa cambio
de unas rayas de cocaína o un regalo o
una pequeña cantidad de dinero y la
conclusión fue que eran casos casos
aislados que no se puede achacar a
ninguna a ninguna responsabilidad
política lo que está ocurriendo que el
problema son los proxenetas
evidentemente que sabemos que el
problema son los proxenetas pero tu
administración pública tu responsable
político que has hecho que han hecho
para evitar que las niñas caigan en
manos de los ricos
según su encuesta al menos un centenar
de menores bajo tutela se dedican a la
prostitución los educadores de los
centros de acogida están agobiados como
atestigua claudia que acaba de cumplir
18 años antes de cumplir la mayoría de
edad vivió en cinco centros de palma
tratan a los niños como si fueran
literalmente culpables de lo que les ha
pasado en su gran mayoría casi todos los
los equipos de educadores de los centros
al menos que he estado yo no estaban
preparados no estaban preparados para
niños con problemas emocionales que son
la gran mayoría realmente de los que
entran en centros pero yo no le desearía
a ningún niño que vive con sus familias
por muy mal que los traten que entraran
en un centro jamás
en mallorca todos los centros de acogida
son gestionados por organizaciones
privadas bajo contrato con la región en
este establecimiento que parece un
centro de detención los casos de abusos
sexuales fueron denunciados por alfonso
donde ha habido
problemas
[Música]
como responsable de una asociación local
acusa a la administración de la isla y a
la dirección de este establecimiento
disponemos de pruebas que acreditan que
en algunos casos concretos en los que ha
habido abusos sexuales entre los propios
niños no se han seguido los protocolos
que determina el gobierno y que
determina la ley y hay una gran falta
por parte de la administración de
-garantizar
y la seguridad de las niñas y de los
niños y que esto no vuelva a pasar
alfonso presentó una denuncia ante la
oficina anticorrupción de la isla
a pesar de las miles de impugnaciones
españa no tiene previsto cambiar el
funcionamiento del sistema por el
contrario una ley de infancia reforzará
pronto los poderes de la administración
francisco y anabel no volverán a ver a
su hija hasta que sea mayor de edad tras
cinco años de una dura lucha maría y
nicolás intentan recuperar esos años
perdidos
[Música]
hasta aquí el programa reporteros de la
semana recuerde que para sintonizar este
y los programas anteriores puede
ingresar a nuestra página web france24
puntocom hasta la próxima
[Música]